So Lady Gaga, you are incredible.
You've become an icon.
No, I haven't. No.
Alright. You won't admit it, but I'm gonna say it to you.
You are a fashion icon.
I'm impressed. I am loving your music.
What is your inspiration for your music?
I'm really, really inspired by my friends in New York City,...
...the art scene on the Lower East Side, and the 70s, and David Bowie, and Studio 54,...
...and media culture, and obsession with fame.
I totally see that.
How amazing! Obsession with fame when I'm standing here with Mrs. Fame.
And I read a recent interview where you said that you liked me and my sister.
I do. Well, you guys went to my school.
I'm really very excited that you're here.
It's so funny 'cause I get asked about you on almost every interview...
...and then like, "Did you know? Are we best friends?"...
...and I said, "No, but I'm sure I'll meet her."
And I always thought that "Stars are Blind" was one of the greatest records ever, you know.
Quite honestly, it's a great pop record.
Oh my God! Thank you.
I'd love to do a song with you.
I love her!
But it's gonna take a lot more than one damn single to make me an icon.
Honey, please. You're taking it over.
I had the most impressive go-go dancer on the planet.
I was her backup.
I should have paid you.
No, you were front and center spotlight go-go.
No, I was the backup dancer.
It was like the old days.
Anything we do would be a surprise, so you guys can't know anything.
Bye-bye!
It's a secret. Bye guys!